mein name ist luca und meine damen und
herren wir schauen uns heute gemeinsamen
photoshop fels an das hier ist das erste
foto und auf dem ersten blick denkt man
erst mal hey da ist ja alles in ordnung
da wird dir ausverkauft und die wollen
das angebot schmackhaft machen und da
noch ein pärchen hinstellen allerdings
hat das hat das kleine beine das hier
ist das nächste foto und zweier das
gefährt hat einfach kein körper also
dass medien hier hat quasi einfach ein
pferd getötet und hält jetzt den kopf
ich will hatten sie hier sehen wir
barack obama mit seiner frau michelle
obama und die hände
naja also mich hat anscheinend zwei
rechte hände beim nächsten photoshop
fail denke ich mir einfach hey so dumm
kann man doch eigentlich gar nicht sein
auf den allerersten blick denkt man sich
vielleicht erst mal wissen der fehler
naja das ist
[Musik]
als nächstes habe ich den photoshop feld
von euch von einer airline und zwar
machen die es ja oft so dass sie dann in
das fenster reinigen welche
sehenswürdigkeiten packen hier hätte ich
allerdings als passagieren angst dass
ich jeden moment in den fluss knalle das
hier war das plakat von mazda zum genfer
autosalon und wenn man mal ran zoomt
jahre sieht man die iss mich wirklich
gefahren auf der straße hier wird eine
vorlaut schlafanzughose verkauft und die
hände ja das komplett normale hände
reiben wir allerdings direkt beim thema
händler und zwar ist das hier das cover
der world gewesen aus dem sommer 2017
und er irgendwie drei hände aber bleiben
wir doch wirklich einfach ein bisschen
beim thema hände und zwar dass hier die
damen wie hat sich ihre kreditkarte
anscheinend drauf geklickt auf ihre via
kuppen und wo wir gerade beim thema
hände sind freunde das hier ja das ist
die richtige
so hätten wir den fall richtig und riss
dabei freude
wir bleiben bei den händchen das hier
ist das plakat dass jemand auf dem weg
zu seinem gym entdeckt hat und der abend
dann das foto hier lasse ich euch
einfach mal so stehen ihr könnt ihr mal
kurz schauen hey wo ist hier der
photoshop fail schreibt es mal und in
die kommentare habe er kurz fünf
sekunden zeit für scott jetzt in die
kommentare
43 21 das ist aber dass wir
wahrscheinlich haben die sich halt
einfach gedacht hey wir haben schönen
ausblick warum machen wir die stimme da
nicht einfach weg hier sieht die
werbeanzeige eigentlich noch ganz gut
aus wenn man dann allerdings mal raus
und sie die drei mädels da oben
irgendwie 7 unterkörper haben apropos
komische körper dieser hals sie sieht
nicht so gesund aus hier wurden richtig
gekonnt einfach erbsen nachruf dem reis
gesetzt und was mit ihrem kopf passiert
es keine ahnung deshalb ein foto was
millionenfach gedruckt wurde und zwar
dass hier sehr einfach zwei rechte füße
das nächste bild finde ich hart creepy
uns weiß hier im spiegel einfach das
gleiche bild gewählt worden von den
medien dass sich apples verstören aus
sie sieht einfach so hofft er wird sich
ihre freunde gleich aufessen freundin
kommt mir allerdings nur zu einer
werbung die samsung tatsächlich damals
so ausgespielt hat uns war dieser hier
auf den ersten blick sieht wieder alles
okay aus allerdings wenn man mal hier an
sieht man dass man mit dem handy
anscheinend in die zukunft schauen kann
als nächstes haben wir eine werbeanzeige
eines unternehmens die gerade auf
mitarbeitersuche sind und ich zeige euch
einfach mal dass sie jetzt die anzeige
man denkt sie auf den ersten blick was
ist daran falsch
ich suche euch mal diesen bereich heran
ich glaube wir kriegen konnten sie noch
spiegeln kommen wir allerdings nun doch
schon zum letzten photoshop helfer heute
meine lieben freunde diesen photoshop
ferien möchte ich euch wieder als
kleines rätsel präsentieren
ich werde euch nicht sagen was daran
falsch sondern ihr habt hier
fünf sekunden zeit euch das ganze
anzuschauen also schreibt jetzt und in
die kommentare was hier dran die
eventuell falsch sein könnte
anders stelle sich vor die videoseite
ist aber entweder liebe freunde werden
zu einer fotoshow pence gefallen hat er
das gerne einen daumen hoch unter diesem
video da schreibt mir und in die
kommentare
die nächste woche einen zweiten teil von
hochladen sondern es gibt so unfassbar
viele photoshop sales im internet fällt
übrigen gerade auf dass ich hier so
einen fetten kräften pickel habe also
sorry dass ihr denen die ganze zeit
beobachten muss erst dann sind neue
klamotten im lokal - shop.de
rausgekommen unter anderem dieses look
to you better t shirt oder auch dieser
blau-weißes mai die who die also falls
ihr bock auf ein neues merchandise stück
habt und auf einen signierten später
dann schaut gerne im luca - shop.de mal
vorbei das würde mich sehr freuen
ansonsten wird das heute wieder beendet
[Musik]